after MTV's jackass became a rowdy
cultural phenomenon thousands of young
men who are inspired by their pranks
tried to do the same thing the justice
since cleared and roman atwood has
emerged as the most successful jackass
disciple the columbus ohio resident owns
two mega popular youtube channels
through which he performs pranks all
over the world and worlds of legends
like steve-o and the Dudesons he's also
taken his viral videos to the big screen
producing a full-length movie called
natural born pranksters but if you think
Roman Atwood is just an overnight
success who gets paid to goof around on
camera all day you couldn't be more
wrong let's find out about the Roman
afterwards before all the fame it soul
begins on May 28 1983 Roman Atwood was
born in Miller's ports Ohio this
relationship of the camera started not
long after and he soon became obsessed
with shooting and editing stupid videos
saved up like 300 bucks bought my first
camera when I was like a kid and the
only reason I ever started filming was
because I wanted to edit I love to edit
why junior high he graduated to shooting
and editing sketch comedy videos with
his friends that's around the time when
he really checked out emotionally with
school he claims that he just couldn't
see how his classes would prepare him
for a world of video and often fell
asleep in the seat as ass wouldn't put
it I don't need to learn about World War
2 to make these videos he also fell in
love with a fellow student named Shanna
Riley whom he married in 2001 five
months after they graduated having no
more interesting college than high
school afterward opted out of higher
education despite his teachers warnings
that had make nothing of his life if he
didn't get a bachelor's rough times to
support his new wife and video-making
obsession atwood took a job working in
his family's business and so it's
discouraged by the time spent away from
his video making habits the spices
depression he still made videos on the
side with his friends and brother Dale
afterward and work on various film
projects and commercial around Columbus
one such project was a DVD of Ashford
and his friends collectively called the
Nerd Herd during jackass bio comedy in
2006 Atwood and his brother traveled
around the country with the Warped Tour
selling hundreds of copies a year after
that after word got what he believed
would be his big break when a friend
invited him up from Los Angeles
work on a movie however when he arrived
on set the young videographer realized
it was not what they'd hoped it was this
little low-budget thing not a movie at
all even still asked would seem to be
gaining more momentum in his
professional life than before
unfortunately his personal life was
crumbling while on his LA trip his wife
reportedly cheated on him with a guy who
had helped outward with his videos
absurd didn't find out until 2008 and
describes it as the worst most
devastating time in his life
fortunately bad situations can inspire a
good creativity he saw the divorce of
the wake-up call to completely
rededicate himself to his passion of
comedy and video production the
realization that changed everything
in 2010 he and his friends created women
asked with sketch umpire for almost two
years the group have loaded a video
every Tuesday with the hope of someday
having one go viral despite their high
hopes the video didn't catch on finally
as word got the idea to shoot a prank
video where they pretended to point
empty water cooler on unsuspecting
pedestrians even though the people never
got wet their reactions earns the prank
video more views than all others
combined while they continued uploading
new sketch videos after the cooler prank
the feedback is almost completely
negative so he decided to turn it into a
full-blown prank channel the group got
their first truly viral video when they
started P prank where they pretend to
urinate on the street and people were
fooled even the police and the YouTube
views climbed upward he was really
seemed to love the police pranking part
so somewhere along the way after we
branded the sketch Empire YouTube
accounts as simply Roman Atwood
viral superstardom just as his name came
in to internet fame Atwoods plasma life
began improving as well he started
dating Brittany Smith who soon started
appearing in his videos as well by 2011
he prank for the mast millions of views
and just a year later at would quit the
family business to pursue prank videos
full time his girlfriend later became an
Internet star in her own voice as well
when Atwood posted anniversary pranks
backfires he was trying to prank her on
their five-year anniversary by
pretending he cheated but she saw the
camera before hand and pranked him by
pretending she had cheated - in the end
the joke was on him Oh
[Music]
the video was insanely popular clocking
in over 86 million views and with a big
part of a full-on girlfriend pranking
trend he's carried on over the years
since it's not funny I know it's not
funny it's it's kind of Holly every year
seems to get better and better fights
would if he continues cranking out
videos for his channels and even
promotes a smile more store
keep your eyes peeled because another
viral prank is almost certainly coming
along very soon thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know your love
[Music]